let's play game i like playing games uh
and and maybe we can we can play game
together i'll give you
uh uh an organization and you tell me
zero to ten what your trust score would
be okay instead of doing a speed round
we're going to do a uh uh
organization you tell us what you're are
you a sports guy or no are you somebody
not okay i'm not my sports is uh
international relations i guess and
staying up to date
things like
that
because none of this is sport so this is
fantastic wonderful all right so let's
start zero to ten uh do you trust uh
the general of army navy air force
marines that they have the best interest
for america zero to ten i'm gonna put
that at a six or seven okay cool
all right how about mainstream media
zero no okay how about president of
the united states
that's a tough one because
it's fairly obvious we're dealing with
something that we haven't really dealt
with before which is cognitive decline
in a you know head of state um in this
country but uh so i'm gonna go ahead and
put that at a uh
two or three okay how about china
and i only had two or three only gets
two or three because i still have a
little bit of a hope left in me
i hope to be a positive looking person
that's the only reason it gets that what
an optimistic guy you are man that was
just fantastic how about china zero to
ten oh zero okay how about the um you
know the major virtual governments i'm
talking twitter for you know today
dorsey sign you know uh resigned and a
new guy took over he's going to also get
off the board himself
how about trust and virtual governments
facebook youtube google twitter all
those guys
i'm going to say a one and the only
reason i give it one is because it had
they they had potential they had
potential to uh to have that sort of
trust that uh that we had in established
media back
50 years ago 100 years ago um but it
doesn't exist anymore do you think they
can still change do you think it can
change i think it's too big of a machine
okay
okay uh how about the the top ten
richest men and women in america i'm
talking bezos you know you talk uh elon
musk all those guys top ten
do you trust me i'd have to look at the
list because it does shift so i'm gonna
go with a with a five uh there because i
know i know some of those guys in that
in that top ten list um and i i trust
them implicitly um but uh but some of
the others uh and then some of the ones
that i don't know that i've just met in
passing that uh that i don't
um
yeah so it's it's so i'm gonna give it a
five just because that list does does
change how about the one a lot of those
people are self-made i mean you look at
some of these questions i mean yeah and
that's the people i was talking about
earlier that get up today how about if i
give specifics bezos musk buffett uh
gates
uh and and let's stay at that those four
names yeah musk and buff on the on the
positive side the other two probably on
the other okay
so still puts me on five so puts me at
50 50. jack how about the wonderful
journalists that we have in america
yeah there are so few actual journalists
um you have to really
seek out um people that are doing that
job like a glenn greenwald or you have
to seek out those people that are after
the truth no matter where
it falls uh without trying to manipulate
that data or write things in a certain
way so that it supports their ideology
and their personal agenda so you really
have to do the homework on quote unquote
journalists because there are so few
these days that are doing it in the
in the tradition that we think of as
journalists in this country going out
after the truth um exposing the truth uh
holding
the leader's feet to the fire exposing
corruption speaking truth to power those
things are in short supply these days
how about a
fouchy i just can't yeah let's just put
that at a
let's put that at a one because of the
hope factor
did you see him on face the nation today
did you did you see him i didn't i saw a
couple of headlines but i i did not dive
in yet i mean if you want to have a
motivating day about 2022 watch it it
will inspire you it's it's a very really
it's a very uh sarcastically very
optimistic is is the direction i'm going
with it
uh
yeah you know it's uh it's
i've never seen him this arrogant in an
interview than the one i saw today was a
very little bit weird on how it was you
know typically
he takes a very neutral position
and he'll still go you know you will
know what side he leans towards but
today was uh
if if you don't if these politicians
question somebody like me who's a
scientist i'm the guy that represents
science and we know what we're doing and
here's what we're going to be doing it
was just very concerning on the way he
took the approach you know on uh uh the
angle he took so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye